Monkeypox is a virus that causes fever...
...and a distinctive bumpy rash.
There are two main strains.
The Congo strain is more severe with up to 10 percent mortality.
The West African strain has a fatality rate of 1 percent.
The virus was first found in monkeys in 1958, hence the name,...
...but rodents are now seen as the main source of transmission.
The virus spreads through close contact,...
...both in spillovers from animal hosts...
...and less commonly between humans.
One likely scenario behind the jump in cases is increased travel...
....after COVID restrictions were lifted.
Monkeypox puts virologists on the alert...
....because it is in the smallpox family,...
...although it causes less serious illness.
Smallpox was eradicated by vaccination in 1980...
....and the shot has been phased out,...
...but it also protects against monkeypox.